[موسيقى]
تجمع امريكيون وفلسطينيون واسرائيليين في
بوستن من اجل هدف واحد وهو تعلم الابحار
وكذلك التعلم الاصعب من هذا وهو التعايش
مع بعضهم البعض هذه فرصه لهم للتعرف على
بعضهم والنقاش في مكان تسمع فيه كل
الاراء المشروع يسمى سيز اوف بيس ومعناه
بحار
السلام
[تصفيق]
شايه اسرائيليه من القدس واحمد فلسطيني من
غزه وهنا الكل لديه راي
مسموع تقول شايه ان الوضع صعب لانهم
ياخذون في عده مواضيع مثل القياده والصراع
الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني وذلك ما يمكن ان
يؤدي الى نقاش حاد لكن في النهايه لكل
رايه الخاص اما احمد فيقول انه عاشر سته
من اصدقائه والذين هم اسرائيليون وقد
ساعدوه عند مروره باوقات
صعبه فرشاد ايضا من ايران يقول ان الهدف
من هذه الرحله ليس الخوض في نزاعات ثقافيه
بل التعلم منها اما هؤلاء الاطفال فيعلمون
ان اي موضوع عن الصراع الفلسطيني
الاسرائيلي قد يهز القارب لكنهم مصممون
على التمسك بالسلام ولو فيما بينهم
فقط
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
a